PROFESSOR: A new way
of thinking about this
is based on integral equations.
So it's a nice method.
It's less complicated than
it seems, suddenly leads
to some expressions for
the scattering amplitude.
We'll find another formula for
this quantity, f of k of theta,
when we cannot calculate
it with phase shifts.
But phase shifts
is very powerful
if your problem has
spherical symmetry.
It's probably the
first thing you try,
because there's nothing to
prevent you from finding
a solution, in that case.
OK, so integral equations,
so integral scattering
equation, OK, integral
scattering equation.
So what are we solving?
We're solving minus h
squared over 2m Laplacian,
plus v of r of potential, that
is not necessarily spherical,
equals or acts on a psi of
r, to give you h squared,
k squared over 2m, psi of r.
So it's an equation for
eigenstates, the Schrodinger
equation.
It's good.
It's nice.
And this is what
we've been solving.
We've been solving if for
some particular cases.
The case of physical
interest for us
was when there was a
plane wave coming in
from infinity and this spherical
wave going out at the infinity.
Now, at this moment,
it's probably
convenient to clean up the units
from this equation a little.
So I'll use a notation
in which V of r
is equal to h squared
over 2m, U of r--
U still reminds you of
a potential, I think.
And it's a good thing.
It's a definition of U of r.
It's a definition.
And in that way, I
can get rid of the h
bars, in this
scattering equation.
And what do we get?
We get minus Laplacian plus
U of r, acting on psi of r,
is equal to k squared,
acting on psi of r.
OK, that looks nice.
It probably is nicer
if you put it in a way
that the left hand side is
kind of a nice, simple operator
and the right hand side
involves the potential.
So I'll move it
along, so that I can
pass the now left
squared to the right,
but then make that
the left hand side.
So this will be
Laplacian squared plus k
squared on psi of r is
equal to U of r, psi of r.
OK, so we've done
nothing so far,
except put the equation in a way
that stimulates our thinking.
We kind of think
of the right hand
side as a source and
the left hand side
as kind of the equation
you want to solve.
Sometimes you have an
equation like that.
Then you can get this zero here.
Well that's when the
potential is zero.
But sometimes there's
a bit of potential,
so the solution
feeds back into this.
Whenever you have an equation of
this form, some nice operator--
so this we call nice operator.
Acting on psi, giving your
something that depends on psi--
maybe it's not that
nice or not that simple.
We can try to solve this
using Green's function.
That's what Green's
functions are good for.
So let's try to use
a Green's function.
So what is a Green's function?
It is basically a
way of understanding
what this operator is.
So nice operator must
have a Green's function.
So what is your
Green's function here?
It's called G. And
we'll say it's depends
on r minus r prime.
r prime is an arbitrary point so
far, but here is what it does.
It's basically a solution.
You want this Green's
function to be almost zero,
except they're not
quite equal to zero.
You want it to be equal
to a delta function.
So that's the definition
of the Green's function,
is that thing which is the
solution of a similar equation,
where you have the nice operator
acting on the Green's function
being just a delta function.
It's almost saying that
the Green's function
is the thing that solves
that equation with zero
on the right hand side.
Except that it's
not really zero,
it's a source in
the right hand side,
it's a delta function
of this point.
So you would say maybe,
OK, I don't know.
Why would I care
about this equation?
You care for two reasons.
The first reason is that
this equation is easier
to solve than this
one, doesn't involve
the potential, which
is complicated.
It just involves
a delta function.
So we can have this
G and solve it once,
because it doesn't
involve the potential.
And then the great thing
about this equation
is that it allows you
to write the solution
for the top equation without
having to do any work anymore.
Once you have the Green's
function, you're done.
So let's assume you have
the Green's function.
How would you write the
solution for this equation?
So maybe a superposition,
basically, and we'll
do it using that.
So our aim is to use
this Green's function,
if we had it, to write a
solution for this equation.
So here is the claim.
You write psi of x.
It's going to be given by a
beginning one, psi zero of x.
That is going to be a funny one.
This one solves Laplacian plus
k squared on psi zero of x or r
is equal to zero.
0.
So whenever you have an
equation of this form,
you can add any solution.
Anything that is killed
by this, can be added
to whatever solution you have.
So let's assume that we have a
solution of this form psi zero,
of this form.
Now, here I'll add one more
thing, the important part.
It's going to be an
integral over r prime,
here is the superposition.
I'm going to think
of this potential, U
of r, as kind of existing
at every point r prime.
So I'm going go
write the solution
as a superposition that
involves the Green's function.
So this will be G of r minus
r prime, times U of r prime,
times psi of r prime.
I claim that this is equivalent
to this equation that we have.
That this psi provides--
more than equivalent.
I think the precise
way to say, this
provides a solution of this
equation, the way I've written.
So let's try.
Suppose I calculate
Laplacian plus k
squared on psi of x here?
OK, the first term,
it's already zero.
So Laplacian plus k squared on
psi zero, it's already zero.
And then I come here and I
say, OK, I'm a Laplacian.
I care about r, because
I'm a Laplacian.
I don't care about r prime.
So I come in here.
And I ignore r prime,
ignore r prime.
I cannot ignore this thing.
So we have plus integral
dr prime, Laplacian plus k
squared, acting on G of r minus
r prime, times U of r prime,
psi of r prime.
And now because the
Green's function
was designed to give you a
delta of r minus r prime,
this is an integral that can
be done, the integral over r
prime, and just set the rest of
the integrand at the point r,
because you integrate
over r prime.
And this delta function fires
when r prime is equal to r.
So this gives me
U of r, psi of r.
And that is the equation
I wanted to solve,
the equation that we have here.
So we have turned the problem.
This cannot be
called the solution,
because we have not solved it.
We have turned the problem into
a different kind of problem.
It might even seem
that we've made
the problem worse by turning
this into an integral equation.
There's no derivatives here.
But the function that
we're looking for
appears outside and
inside the integral.
So these things are
called integral equations.
And the power of an
integral equation
is the insight it can give you
once you have an idea of what
the Green's function is.
And also it's a good place to
do recursive approximations.
In that, you can
essentially begin
and say, OK, I know the wave
function is this plus that.
But maybe in some sense,
I can think of this thing
as the leading solution.
I could substitute the
leading solution in here
and try to make
an approximation.
That's going to give you
a nice approximation,
the Born approximation.
We'll see that soon.
That should be all psi r's.
I think I'm using
r's, so I please--
so r's and r's everywhere, yeah,
no difference at this moment.
OK, so the next step is solving
for the Green's function.
We need the Green's function.
Otherwise, we can't make
progress with this equation.
So I'm going to do a simple
solution of the Green's
function, basically by
doing a couple of checks
and saying that is the
answer we're interested in.
And there are several
possible Green's functions.
And depending on the
problem you're solving,
you choose the right
Green's function.
And we'll choose the one
that is suitable for us now.
This is something
that can be done.
The general solutions
can be obtained
by counter integration.
And there's all kinds of
nice methods to do this.
But in fact, in this
case, it's really simple.
You don't need any of
those complicated things.
You can just pretty
much write the solution.
So that's what I'm going to do.
So what do we need for
the Green's function?
So we have a Green's
function that
depends on r minus r prime.
And so it depends on a vector.
So let me simplify
the matter by saying,
OK, since it
depends on a vector,
I'll just first
calculate what this G
of r, the Green's function
of r, when the vector is r.
Or you can think it's when
r prime is equal to zero.
Whatever I find for
G of r, this one
is obtained by
whatever I find here,
put in instead r minus r prime.
So G of r is enough
for what we want to do.
So it should have
Laplacian plus k squared.
And G of r should be for,
not for, but it's delta of r.
So we've looked at that
in fact at the beginning
of this course, not of this
course, of the discussion
of scattering.
We looked at this equation.
In fact, we wanted to solve
it when the right hand
side was zero, to find solutions
of this scattering equation.
And we found that these
G's could be of the form
e to the ikr plus,
minus ikr over r.
Those were the spherical waves
that solved this equation
with zero potential.
Those are our solutions.
Now, it's easy to see that
Laplacian plus k squared
on this G, that has
a plus or a minus,
is equal to zero for
r different from zero.
The formulas for the Laplacian
that you can us for r
different from zero, you
can check that is true.
And it's easy.
You can use that
formula, for example,
that the Laplacian is one
over r the second-- well,
it should be partial.
The second dr squared r,
so psi, psi, like that.
That formula in
one 30 seconds, you
can see that that works
for r different from zero.
But then there's also
a formula that you
know that Laplacian of one
over r from electromagnetism
is minus 4pi pi times
the delta function of r.
It comes from Poisson's
equation in electromagnetism.
So that's saying
Laplacian of the potential
is the charge density.
This is the potential
for a charge.
The charge that r equals
zero is a singularity.
It's something you study.
So here if I put a minus
one over 4pi for G plus,
minus, a minus one over 4pi, the
Laplacian of this whole thing
is zero.
But when you approach zero,
the Laplacian of this function,
this function approaches
just one over r.
That's how it goes to zero.
This goes to one.
And the Laplacian of
one over r gives it
this minus 4pi
cancels with that.
And it will give you
a delta function.
So the delta function will arise
correctly from this quantity.
So I've argued without
solving this equation,
that this does give you a
solution for the Green's
function.
It's Laplacian plus k squared
is zero away from zero.
Unless you approach zero,
it has a right singularity
to give a delta function.
So this is your
Green's function.
As I said many
ways to derive it.
If you want to see
griffiths, see other ways
in which it can be
done, then you can also
check this by doing properly
the vector calculus.
You can think of Laplacian
as divergence of the gradient
and calculate every step.
And it's fun to do it as well.
You check that this works.
So this works.
And now we have to make choices.
And our choices are going to be
adjusted to the problem we're
trying to solve.
We're trying to solve
a scattering problem.
And psi zero
represents a solution.
And from the way we
thought of our waves,
we had psi equal e to the ikz
plus f of theta and phi, e
to the ikr over r.
So it's reasonable
to try to set.
And we're going
to find solutions
by setting psi zero
to be e to the ikz.
It does solve the equation
Laplacian squared plus k
squared equals zero.
And then we're going to set the
Green's function to be G plus.
With a plus here, because we
want solutions of the type
e to the ikr.
We've already decided those
were the solutions we need.
And a Green's function
with a plus in there
is going to generate that.
So those are fine.
You could have chosen another
thing here, an arbitrary
solution.
And you could have
chosen a G minus as well.
And you would get a solution
of the scattering equation.
It would not have much to
do with the solution we're
trying to get.
So let's show that this gives
us this kind of solution we want
to get and gives us
already a formula
for the scattering amplitude.
So let's do that.
For that we just need to write
what the Green's function is
and approximate.
So it will be a first step.
OK, so what do we have?
Psi of r is equal
to e to the ikz.
I'm writing up
this stop equation,
but we now write it with the
right boundary conditions,
which correspond to psi
zero on a particular choice
of the Green's function, v
cubed r prime G of r minus r
prime, U of r prime,
all those are vectors,
and psi of r prime.
All those are vectors,
except G, which
is pretty in that it is
very spherically symmetric.
This G plus, minus of r just
depends on the magnitude
of r, which is very nice.
OK, so a couple of things
that we can do here
and most everybody would do.
Let's G plus of r
minus r prime is
equal to minus one
over 4pi, e to the ik,
length of r minus r prime--
that's what this
is supposed to be.
Over the length of
r minus r prime.
Remember I said to
you that whenever
we have G of r, then
to get the one we need,
we'll just have to replace
the r by r minus r prime.
And here this little r
or r without the vector
is the magnitude of this vector.
So we've put the magnitude
of those vectors there.
Now, people look for
approximations in here.
So here is what we need to do.
Imagine you are the origin.
Here is the potential.
And you have your
system of coordinates.
You are integrating over places
where the potential exists.
So the r prime that
you're integrating
remains inside the
range of the potential.
Here is zero.
And then there is a r, which
is where you are looking at.
And there is an angle
between these two.
Maybe I should make the angle a
little bigger, smaller, I mean,
r.
And in general, we
look always far enough.
This is an exact solution,
but we might as well
consider looking
at psi's that are
located far from the potential.
So we have the idea of what
should we do with this terms.
One thing you can do is to say
that in the denominator here,
r minus r prime is
good enough to set it
to r in the denominator.
And for the numerator, however,
it's a lot more sensitive,
because you have a k here.
And depending on whether
k is large or small--
a small difference
in r minus r prime,
if you're estimating
this and you
make an error comparable
with the wavelength
of your particle, you
make a big mistake.
If you're far way, you're 100
times farther than the range
of the potential, here you're
making a 1% error, no problem.
But if you're making a 1%
error in the estimate of this,
that might be still comparable
to the wavelength of this k.
So you have to be a lot
more careful in the phase,
than you have to be
on the other one.
So for the phase,
phase, we will take
r minus r prime equal
to r minus n, r prime.
So what is n? n is a unit
vector in this direction.
And indeed, approximately,
this distance
here is approximately
equal to the distance
r minus the projection
of r prime into this one.
So that is your
approximate distance.
So here is the final formula
we're going to write today.
I'm running out of time.
But that's what we
wanted to end up with.
So here is what we get.
So G plus of r minus r prime
has become minus one over 4pi r.
The denominator is r.
There's an e to the ikr and then
e to the minus ikn dot r prime.
So that's-- and the
arrows are crucial here.
If I don't put an
arrow somewhere,
it probably means something.
So psi of r is equal to e to the
ikz plus minus one over 4pi r.
The integral over
r prime doesn't
care about this, the cubed r
prime, e to the minus ikn dot
r prime, times U of r prime,
times psi of r prime, all
that multiplied by--
let me take the r out.
e to the ikr over r.
So look at what we obtain.
I just rewrote,
finally, this expression
for the Green's
function over there,
with the integral over r prime
and the Green's function here.
You have this
quantity in brackets.
This quantity in
brackets here is
nothing but the f of theta phi
of the scattering amplitude.
You have this equal to that,
plus e to the ikr over r.
So we'll continue that
next time and finish up
with scattering probably in the
first half of the next lecture.